hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about the importance
of hydrochloric acid or stomach acid
your stomach acid is probably one of the
most important fluids in your entire
body because the Cascade of a negative
effects that occur without this acid are
huge let's go through each one of them
so normally in your stomach you need a
very very strong acid that means a low
pH so one two three so it goes on a
scale from 1 to 14 so one to three is
very very acid so we need a very very
strong acidic stomach and that's why
when people say oh yeah our bodies are
supposed to be alkaline well what about
the stomach they're probably talking
about the blood but your stomach needs
to be very very acid now here's the
thing as you age your you lose your
stomach acid okay and when you lose your
stomach acid a lot of things happen in a
negative way let's just take one thing
if the stomach is not acidic you will
not release the main enzyme called
pepsin now what is pepsin and what is an
enzyme an enzyme is something called a
catalyst or a thing that helps beat up a
chemical reaction in the body it helps
you to break things down or builds
something back up so what's interesting
about enzymes is is they basically don't
necessarily get used up after they do
the work they're kind of like a self
propelling energy that does all the work
but doesn't use up its energy it's
pretty wild it's but it speeds up the
chemical reaction so pepsin is a main
catalyst or enzyme that breaks down
protein okay so that's what it does
but it takes a pH between one two and up
to three to release this enzyme so if
you're not releasing this enzyme you
can't break down protein one of the most
common symptoms would be intestinal gas
that's when we know we're not getting
this release of this pepsin okay you're
also going to get bloating and other
things but what happens too is that
valve on top of the stomach is
controlled by the pH so the valve won't
necessarily close if the pH is not
strong
so that's called acid reflux you know or
GERD that's basically because your
stomach is not asked enough what's
really ironic is the way they treat it
is they give you an anti acid so you're
going to feel better but then you're
going to feel worse because you're
taking the acid out of the system what
they should do is put more acid in there
to fix it but they don't really do that
one of the challenges with having this
valve not closed tightly is that the
enzyme splashes up into not just the
acid but the enzyme can go right up all
the way up your esophagus up into your
your larynx and your vocal cords and
that can create chronic coughing it can
create chronic hoarseness it can create
like that little lump in your throat a
chronic cough irritation asthma that's
because this enzyme is going right up in
here and the main reason is because this
is not acid enough so then it leaks up
into the esophagus so that's one symptom
the three main purposes of the acid or
number one to help break down proteins
number to absorb minerals and number
three kill off microbes so like if you
see like a dog for example eat like yous
like eat raw meat
you know there's microbes and bacteria
and our dog has a really strong stomach
acid and so that acid is just going to
kill all that bacteria well we also have
the acid there to kill microbes as well
in case there's so we cannot have any
extra invading microbes come through the
stomach so it's if we don't have an
ambassador we get a bacterial overgrowth
so you might have extra you know
bacteria that shouldn't be there and you
leaky gut because undigested protein can
leak through the system and create all
sorts of immune reactions because then
it goes through the lymphatic system in
your immune system attacks it as being a
foreign body and bam allergy because
allergies are always two proteins right
so I wonder why it starts with the
stomach acid that's why so many people
if they just get the stomach right
everything will do really really good
and then we have Candida up see normal
in your friendly stomach
in your friendly bacteria in your
stomach and your gut you actually have a
normal Candida in there that's supposed
to be helpful to you it's not a bad
thing it's only when it has an
overgrowth if the pH is not correct if
the pH is too alkaline you'll get an
overgrowth of the fungus type Candida
okay so that will happen and that can
happen in the mouth the vaginal area and
your intestines and your toenails all
over the place so that's one thing also
h pylori h pylori lives in an alkaline
environment in fact it'll it'll even
alkalis your stomach to live it doesn't
survive at an acid medium so normally
like I think most people actually have h
pylori in their stomach that's a
negative microbe I mean it's it's a it's
a neutral microbe that can activate and
cause damage if it's becomes unfriendly
but it's really controlled by the
environment if that environment is too
alkaline that h pile already kicks in
there and you can have all these main
side effects from that inflammation
gastritis all those things so we have
that issue and then we also have rosacea
rosacea is the red face that comes from
low stomach acid as well that's one of
the symptoms GERD we talked about that
acid reflux bloating gas indigestion is
basically all that means is you don't
have enough stomach acid okay it could
be that you're also taking anti acids
which then causing less acid and stomach
or even stress can deplete your asses
your stomach
bad food junk food sugar a lot of things
take that asset out of stomach diarrhea
you know can do it as well because you
lose all your stomach acid vomiting
people that have a bulimia because they
vomit they can lose their stomach acids
so that's that's some causes now let's
get into undigested protein in your
stomach if you can't break down protein
in your stomach and break down into
amino acid then you can't build body
tissues so there goes the hail hair nail
skin muscle protein not to mention
neurotransmitters like adrenaline
tryptophan all these amino acids that
are supposed to be there to help build
your hormones
I mean serotonin is a pleasure hormone
so if it's made in protein so if you're
that stomach is not right you're not
gonna have the building blocks to make
those neurotransmitters or like hormone
type things but they travel to the
nervous system and then the last thing
that we'll do it to controls the
absorption of minerals so without that
stomach being pH you can't poll in
calcium
you can't pull in magnesium or zinc or
iron so you have something called anemia
even pernicious anemia basically it's
low iron and it could be also b12
different forms of anemia but if you
can't pull in that iron then you get a
whole series of additional side effects
one is anxiety OCD sleeping problems
tinnitus it's ringing the ear
palpitations of the heart hair loss it
genus like you can see the cascade of
effects that occur from not having the
stomach right and because you have an
acid reflux condition or GERD you're
thinking I have too much acid and you're
basing all the therapies on the wrong
solution and that's where people kind of
go from bad to worse and they're
treating all these other conditions when
they if they just fix the stomach a lot
of things will improve so I think fixing
the stomach will fix all the different
PHS in the body that's just my personal
opinion when the b12 you need a strong
acid in your stomach to digest button
b12 so if you don't have b12 you have
visual changes gait problems fatigue
tingling numbness memory problems a
whole bunch of things because b12 is
involved in your DNA that's involved in
your brain tissue it's involved in your
immune system your energy your
metabolism so many things so there what
I recommend of course you can some of
the other videos I recommend apple cider
vinegar for those people that don't like
to tape up soda vinegar I do have
something that you can take in a pill
form and it's called apple cider vinegar
plus because I I have 50% of this is
absolute vinegar powder and 50% of its
betaine hydrochloride which is an
acidifier so this is what I take
between me I'm actually right before a
meal to acidify my stomach and what it
does is it starts to naturally give you
the acids that you're missing so you can
start building up that acidifier and
start to really correct the deeper cause
I always recommend taking one before a
meal with each meal and then the next
day take two before each meal and then
take three before each meal until you
feel really really really good in your
stomach and you're digesting because you
want to gradually increase the acid some
people need a lot of Siddha fires to
help fix your stomach and they might
even need six initially to fix it and
then it you can back off over time but
you want to gradually go into it you
don't want to just take the huge amount
wrap up the bat but it's more I like it
because it's corrective because once you
have how to chloric acid your body will
tend to actually recycle it and it'll
start working better so it's a great
solution to fix a lot of problems
naturally without having to make it
worse okay so it's more corrective than
anything so I just wanted to touch on
the importance of how to chloric acid
and give you some of the functions of
what it does and a deeper understanding
of the of some myths that people have
about it so thanks for watching I'll see
in the next video